This is the marvelous molecule that makes up our genomes, DNA.
>> I feel like you hear about DNA everywhere.
>> It's true. The DNA name and structure, its visual
itself, is something that's come to permeate our culture. You've
probably heard references to it in pop culture, movies like
Jurassic Park and Gattico, or TV shows like CSI and Bones.
>> I love those shows.
[UNKNOWN]
I mean I recognize the shape and I hear the name all the time, so
>> Yeah I mean the shape is it's most
defining characteristic. In fact, the structure's so well-known people all
over the world use it in works of art,
design, architecture. But not only is the structure appealing, it's
very important in revealing the secrets of how DNA
does what it does in our genomes. So if we
have any hope of defining what our genome is.
We need to go take a look at what DNA
is made of, and where its shape comes from.
>> That sounds reasonable. Let's go do that.